good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3812
containment class ketter
disruption class eki
and risk class danger
special containment procedures
scp-3812 is currently only partially
contained see containment proposal brief
below for more information
class containment proposal brief
scp-3812 is to be constantly monitored
by mobile task force ganymede 66
starlight knights who are to maintain a
5 kilometer quarantined area of
exclusion around
scp-3812 the acting mobile task force
gy66 team lead in conjunction with
site-86 research staff is allowed fiat
authority in regards to any aspect of
scp-3812 containment special care must
be taken in order to prevent unnecessary
exposure to
scp-3812
current containment efforts focus on
mitigating scp-3812's influence on
population centers as well as research
into the full breadth of scp-3812's
anomalous capabilities in order to
establish a more comprehensive
containment procedure information
security teams are to monitor all forms
of digital media in order to prevent
widespread awareness of scp-3812
scp-3812 has an active aggressive
anomalous influence on reality
scp-3812 is capable of altering events
throughout time to prevent its
containment due to the nature of these
alterations it is highly unlikely that
any individual affected by scp-3812's
anomalous influence will be aware that
they are affected it is highly likely
that most affected individuals no longer
exist as a result of
scp-3812's influence though any attempt
to deduce how often this has happened
would be speculative
description
scp-3812 is a reality altering entity
due to scp-3812's latent effect on
reality it is nearly impossible to
describe scp-3812
in any meaningful way all that is known
about scp-3812 is that it was once sam
howell a non-anomalous african-american
human being who was believed to have
died in 1996 sometime shortly after its
death
scp-3812 was observed rising out of its
grave and disappearing
scp-3812 was brought to the foundation's
attention after its presence resulted in
the demolition of an apartment building
in warsaw poland due to its anomalous
capabilities
scp-3812's appearance varies
significantly making it exceedingly
difficult to track
scp-3812 is currently located at the
location on screen over the south
pacific ocean
scp-3812 exhibits signs of an extremely
advanced eigem inviter schizophrenia
complex specifically extreme paranoia
extreme dysphoria extreme mania and
depression inability to properly
perceive their surroundings inability to
discern the difference between the real
and imagined inability to differentiate
between living and dead beings inability
to control expressions of emotion
hearing voices that are not there seeing
things that are not there and feeling or
otherwise experiencing stimuli that do
not exist etc
in the 20 years since scp-3812 was
initially discovered these symptoms have
grown steadily worse originally scp-3812
was responsive to questioning and sought
help in managing its condition from
foundation researchers over time
scp-3812 became more isolated and
withdrawn eventually becoming entirely
unresponsive and acting in erratic and
unpredictable ways currently scp-3812 is
not able to accurately perceive the
world around it and will occasionally
alter reality in order to diminish the
discrepancy between how it perceives
something and the way that something is
in actuality due to this it is
impossible to know how often reality has
been modified only how often scp-3812
has not created a clean alteration and
is left behind evidence of its influence
on reality
scp-3812 is impossible to contain with
any form of containment cell
scp-3812 will alter reality to remove
the containment cell or move itself to
another location drastically impeding
containment efforts
scp-3812 seems to subconsciously resist
attempts at containment as well even if
it is caught unaware
scp-3812 cannot be tranquilized or
amnesticized as scp-3812 will alter
reality to remove or eliminate any
threats to itself or its freedom of
movement because of this current
containment efforts focus on mitigating
damage and expressions of scp-3812
symptoms as opposed to outright
containment
over time
scp-3812 has become significantly less
humanoid in appearance and is now only
vaguely humanoid and occasionally
manifests in a variety of shapes and
appearances additionally scp-3812
produces a latent anomalous effect on
local reality specifically in the form
of temporal and spatial distortions
surrounding the entity these distortions
are occasionally accompanied by random
violent outbursts that may dramatically
shift or damage local space and time
while scp-3812 is usually docile and
aimless its random outbursts are
invariably fatal to any living creature
nearby and can be extremely disastrous
on a massive scale if not properly
contained
scp-3812 manifested in its current form
at its current location on july 19 2015.
addendum
3812-1 interview
note the following is an excerpt from an
interview with scp-3812 in 1999
scp-3812 was initially contained by
foundation personnel and questioned at
site-17 where it began receiving
treatment for its mental disease
tell me how you're feeling today
uncomfortable
uneasy
can you tell me why
there's a
uh voices like usual
things i can see you know
the same
is there something wrong
i just
the things i see aren't going away there
are more of them
different
i know i sound crazy but it's like i'm
addressing a dozen people at the same
time
and more every day and
it hurts pretty bad
i know i sound nuts
i'm sorry it's all right you don't sound
nuts
we just want to help you get better i i
don't know if you do or i don't know if
you can
in the story
you don't try to help
in the story
what story this is going to sound crazy
seriously but i can
i can see what you're thinking
i know you're afraid
you're scared of what i might do
and here in a minute you'll
i don't know how to get it out of my
head
how do i start telling do this if i even
can i i don't even think he can
who is he you
no you can't see him
i can't
i think he was above us at one point
but he's below me now
yes i see you there
i don't know what he did to me
but i'm pretty messed up man
if you can figure something out here
that would be great because i really
feel like i'm losing it i'm scared too
man you've got you've got to do
something and you've got to help me out
here please god please who are you
it doesn't matter
addendum 38 12 2
memo from the office of dr yamamara
regarding the 2109 2015 report on
scp-3812's behavioral instability and
the implication of existential threats
from the office of dr karl yamamura
i usually don't lead into these things
with hyperbole so you'll have to take me
at my word when i say that i believe
scp-3812
is the most dangerous anomaly on earth
and potentially in the universe i know
many of my co-workers would probably
balk at me for saying that and i've
tried to reject the notion a fair few
times myself but we have a lot of
evidence to suggest that i'm right and
that's really bad for pretty much
everything
when james coldman and carlos razewski
devised the hume as a way to measure
alterations in local reality they
probably saved the foundation reality
benders have always been the footlong
thorn in our side the one we really
couldn't get our heads around how do you
combat or contain something that can
blink you into non-existence
thanks to dr scranton we had the reality
anchors but they only worked half the
time and were less than useless the
other half we didn't know how they
worked and we weren't using them right
this changed when we began to measure
reality and compare it to a baseline we
found out that our reality anchors could
be tuned and adjusted and that not all
anchors were the same it was a windfall
for those of us who work in existential
sciences and suddenly type greens
weren't the same kind of boogeyman they
had been in the past
i mention all of this to give context to
what i'm about to say
our equipment cannot detect scp-3812
it's not a machine error we've tested
our equipment countless times and it's
always consistent it's not user error
we've poured over and studied thousands
of hours of logs from our tests
and it's all come up clean we have
checked and rechecked more times than i
can count over the last few months and
the results are
consistent so far as we can tell this
means one of three things and none of
them are good the first is that scp-3812
has an extremely low hume value
something that our equipment which
exists in a space with a much higher
hume baseline wouldn't be able to detect
the problem with this is that it creates
a false vacuum we've been working under
the assumption that our baseline is the
absolute minimum if it turns out that
this thing exists at a much lower hume
value then that means that there are
lower hume values than what we believed
were the minimum which means any day our
entire reality could fall into that
existence and that would pretty much be
the ball game
the second option is that scp-3812
exists at a much higher hume value than
anything we've ever tested this would be
pretty bad as we've pointed out counters
and anomalies that some would consider
to be gods and we've gotten readings off
them that being said something with a
hume value so high that it cannot be
measured with our equipment would likely
have already destroyed us since scp-3812
hasn't done that it's likely not this
the last option is the worst the last
option is that scp-3812
cannot be measured in humes
because it's doing something else
whatever fundamental aspect of its
nature that allows it to warp reality is
not the same aspect as literally
everything else we have ever come across
scranton hypothesized that there might
be higher and lower dimensions of
reality different levels of manipulation
in the grand construction of the
universe the difference between
manipulating a rock with your hands and
manipulating a rock with an atom bomb he
called the thing being manipulated the
narrative and suggested that the
narratives were stacked on top of either
other each creating the narrative of the
narrative below it and so on until you
reach some sort of dead space below them
all
if that's the case and scp-3812 is
legitimately a type green of some higher
order we are absolutely
the singular power to manipulate every
facet of any and every aspect of
everything we've ever encountered in the
hands of someone genetically doomed by
eichmann vita it's a miracle it hasn't
happened yet
even by accident so far as we know we
can't kill it so we either wait for it
to die if it even can
or continue to pretend we have some
semblance of control over it until it
shreds our universe like some sort of
cosmic wood chipper
in truth it's probably better for us
that it's insane it isn't capable of
comprehending the kind of things that it
could do to us it just acts on impulse
and things change to fit those impulses
but since it's as locked in as it is
those changes stay local imagine if it
got the idea in its head that it didn't
like the concept of empathy and suddenly
empathy no longer existed we have
evidence that suggests that may have
already happened a few sparse texts and
individual accounts of half-forgotten
memories all consistent with a dirty
reality alteration all point to the idea
that as recently as the 1980s there was
a concept potentially even something as
fundamental as an emotion that no longer
exists
an entire concept wiped clean from
reality and the collective consciousness
of all sentient beings just like you'd
wipe a bug off your windshield
the point of all this which i expand
upon in the report is that we need to
start figuring something out about this
one quickly every second we don't come
up with a way to neutralize scp-3812 is
one second closer to scp-3812 becoming
completely disassociated from its
consciousness and all of us getting
tossed in the aforementioned proverbial
wood chipper
stay in touch call my office if you need
any more resources follow any convincing
lead you can and communicate
with each other
we'll talk more soon
yamamara signing off
addendum 3812 3
excerpt from dr yamamara's report on
scp-3812's behavioral instability and
the implication of existential threats
page 194
pk class all-in-one existential
pandemonium event
an entity or force with access to higher
energy metaphysical dimensions would
perceive our reality similarly to how we
perceive the reality of characters in a
comic book and just how we are able to
at whim change the story simply by
telling it differently this higher
energy being would be able to
effortlessly make alterations to not
just local reality but reality as a
whole altering the baseline and changing
its most fundamental aspects
at the 2015 foundation summit on
existential threats dr darius saint john
hypothesized that such an entity were at
limited to a human intelligence without
modification to allow for the perception
of higher levels of reality would suffer
from an overexposure of narrative this
entity when faced with this overexposure
might attempt to ease itself by
collapsing all lower energy realities
into something perceptible the effect
this would have on lower energy
narratives would be catastrophic as
multiple realities became compressed
into the same metaspace they would not
be immediately destroyed rather their
parts would become intertwined in such
an incomprehensible way that not only
would the ability for conscious thought
be nearly immediately annihilated
physical space would become so
compressed and broken that the
boundaries between all lower realities
would cease to exist completely
this chaotic state of all things
described as existential pandemonium was
the focus of dr st john's proposal for
the description of a new k-class
scenario the pk class all-in-one
existential pandemonium scenario this
proposal was denied due to the scenario
in question being purely speculative and
one would require too many impossible
things to occur before its inception
addendum 38 12 4 log of scp-3812
alteration events
note the following is a log of events in
which scp-382 in some way altered
reality due to the nature of these
alterations the likelihood of the event
having actually ever taken place is
listed alongside the severity of the
alteration in question notably this log
is incomplete and subject to change as
more information is discovered
event date 09 13 1997 event description
scp-3812 is observed walking across a
stretch of desert in the american
southwest a path of temperate climate is
present along
scp-3812's travel path this climate
diminishes slowly over time severity of
alteration minor
event date 0301 1998
scp-3812 passes over a road near blithe
california three cars approaching
scp-3812 are annihilated within 20
meters of scp-3812
severity of alteration moderate
event date 12 12 1999 event description
evidence suggests that scp-3812
caused the disappearance of an entire
island off the coast of california no
fewer than 200 individuals in southern
california have a vague recollection of
such an island existing and 14 people
were unable to justify the
disappearances of family members who
lived in the area at the time
additionally a single ship moored to a
dock is discovered at the bottom of the
sea near where the island is believed to
have been severity of alteration severe
o2 16 2000 event description testing of
determined that the entity exuded a
powerful
anti-metaphysical field similar to the
foundation's scranton reality anchor
this entity was brought into contact
with scp-3812
which was located near the hospital
the entity had no noticeable detrimental
effect on scp-3812's abilities and
instead caused scp-3812 to become
violent resulting in an explosion that
destroyed the hospital the remnants of
scp later reclassified as scp-239
were later recontained severity of
alteration severe
event date 1-1 2002 event description a
powerful explosion is recorded in
eastern russia
scp-3812 is present at the site of the
explosion no other information is
available severity of alteration severe
event date 05 29 2004 event description
evidence suggests that for a period of
three days the country of mongolia
ceased to exist while public knowledge
of this event is functionally
non-existent a significant enough
percentage of the local population with
fractured memories of the event have
given credit to this theory orbital
models indicate that during this period
the earth's orbit was dramatically
affected by as much as 1.5 percent
severity of alteration extremely severe
event date 0902 2004 event description
records indicate that on this date every
human on earth simultaneously heard
scp-3812 screaming and begging for help
in their heads it is unknown how this
event was removed from the public
consciousness but no humans alive on
this date appear to remember this event
occurring severity of alteration
moderate
event date 11 11 2006 event description
during routine server maintenance
foundation information security teams
discover 56 broken employee database
files consistent with an improperly
altered personnel database used in
testing the contents of these files are
unknown it is not known if these files
correspond to individuals who are once
employed by the foundation severity of
alteration moderate
event date 02 28 2009 during an attempt
by foundation personnel to contain
scp-3812
using a newly discovered anomalous logic
construct
became hostile towards containment teams
no fewer than 62 foundation personnel
disappeared across 17 sites as well as a
significant portion of local wildlife
the resulting explosion killed another
seven members of containment personnel
and left a crater roughly 850 meters in
diameter in the canadian yukon in the
wake of the explosion scp-3812 had
disappeared and
scp-2719 was discovered within the
crater severity of alteration severe
event date unknown event description a
record recovered from a foundation
deepwell information security vault
indicates that at some point in the past
one or more governments discovered
scp-3812
independent of the foundation and
attempted to terminate it as a result of
these attempts
scp-3812 swiftly removed them and any
memory of them from the earth this
record indicates that this event was
followed by the activation of scp-2000
which scp-3812 immediately severely
damaged to impede its progress why
scp-3812 was unable to totally destroy
scp-2000 is unknown but no other records
of this event exist notably shortly
after the discovery of this record it
disappeared from the deepwell archive
severity of alteration extremely severe
addendum 3812 5
event
scp-3812 was detected moving through a
sparsely populated region in paraguay
towards a more populated region on the
argentinian border as foundation
personnel moved to intercept scp-3812
a series of unexpected phenomena
occurred these phenomena are listed
below in the order they occurred
1935
hrs
scp-3812 is attacked by a large number
of local wildlife
scp-3812 repels these attacks but
appears in some way startled
1914 hrs a massive sinkhole appears
below scp-3812
extending down an indeterminate distance
scp-3812
falls but is immediately returned to
ground level and the sinkhole vanishes
1950 hrs a large number of objects fall
from the sky onto scp-3812
these are later determined to have been
tungsten rods though the origin of them
is uncertain the rods appear to pierce
scp-3812's body but upon further
inspection simply disintegrate within
half a meter from scp-3812
after the first three rods fall over a
40-second period of time they are
accompanied by no fewer than 3000 others
that fall in rapid succession each
having the same results as the previous
despite this being clearly visible from
nearby towns nobody outside of
foundation personnel appears to have
noticed it taking place
2014 hrs multiple incorporeal instances
of scp-3812 begin to fall away from the
central mass of the entity as if they
were dying
scp-3812 is unaffected each of the
incorporeal instances becomes hostile to
the main instance and attacks it
scp-3812 does not initially seem to
notice the instances but eventually
appears to look in their direction
causing them to disappear suddenly
2019 hrs an explosion occurs at the
point in which scp-3812 is standing
scp-3812 is unaffected several other
larger explosions occur immediately
afterwards as with the tungsten rods
this is somehow not noticed by the local
populace
2039 hrs a gravitational anomaly later
determined to be a freestanding stable
naked singularity appears in front of
scp-382
scp-3812 passes through the singularity
unfazed which dissipates shortly
afterwards
for a period of 72 hours after beginning
additional anomalous phenomena occur
around scp-3812
all of which failed to kill scp-3812
eventually local populations were
evacuated and amnestics were given to
witnesses
after this 72-hour period scp-3812
was observed to glow white momentarily
and then shift sideways and then
disappear immediately afterwards the
anomalous phenomena ceased after a
period of absence lasting eight weeks
scp-3812 reappeared at its current
position above the south pacific ocean
shortly afterwards foundation overwatch
command received a message on a secure
server access to which is limited to
overseers alone the contents of this
message are as follows
a quick explanation in case you haven't
caught on yet
your world has rules
physical rules that cannot be broken you
call them the laws of the universe and
they're what you study in physics
chemistry etc those laws create the
narrative of your reality the
unchangeable story that defines your
existence once the laws are established
and the ball is set in motion it cannot
be changed i wrote the laws of your
universe and as such i created the
narrative this isn't the first time i've
done this but it was the first time i
tried something like this specifically i
wanted to create something that by
definition superseded everything that
superseded it i wanted to see how many
layers there are if the stack of
narratives really do go on forever
upward the mistake i made was when i
didn't realize that by making him
supersede everything that supersedes him
he's also superseding himself
i'm sorry i think i've picked up pretty
badly this time i've tried everything i
can think of but i can't undo him i
don't really understand how but i think
he's above me now and whatever is above
me too because whoever wrote my
narrative isn't happy about this i don't
know where he's at now but i think he
exists in all of our realities
simultaneously eventually he'll either
reach the top or just keep going and
neither option is good
i'm going to keep looking for some way
to fix this
you should too
b
addendum 38 12 6 excerpt from
supersession and the echelon of reality
by dr robert scranton
i'm attaching this excerpt from one of
dr scranton's articles about the nature
of reality if scp-3812 is some higher
level entity there might be something to
be gleaned in here
okay yamamara
i'm often asked by my colleagues dr
scranton do you believe in gods many
might feel as if this is a silly
question
but i do not believe it is a silly
question just the wrong question the
idea of a god implies that an entity
supersedes you in a complete and
infinite way
something that holds a power without
limits that not only knows the whole
story but can write and rewrite that
story at will
within our reality i do not believe that
any such thing exists there are a number
of entities that we're aware of in one
way or another that hold tremendous
power over our universe many would call
these beings gods and while they
certainly hold many of the
characteristics of a god
they are still limited their reach and
scope is limited to our reality just
like we are and though they may carry
more weight within it they are no less
bound to it as we are
so then what would truly constitute a
god this entity would have to totally
supersede our reality to be able to look
over our reality not like we would look
over ants but like how we would look
over our thoughts and ideas of being so
totally separate from our reality that
we may as well be words on a page to it
this entity a true author of creation
could be considered a god
but what of that entity would it not
share the same limitations within its
reality as we do with ours it may exist
within a higher tier than us but surely
it must follow the same rules as we do
but who sets those rules an entity
higher than that one that supersedes not
only us but the entity that supersedes
us and the one after that as well where
did the echelon originate then who or
what was the original architect of the
architecture
it is unlikely that we will ever know
anything about the being or beings that
supersede us if they even exist not in
any tangible way let alone any being
that would supersede them it may very
well be that we are just one of an
infinite number of realities stacked on
top of each other in every direction
influencing those below us and being
influenced by those above us this
echelon upon which sits ourselves and
everything that ever was or will be
would likely be the most fundamental
aspect of the organization of creation
the very foundation of all things
i have often hypothesized on the nature
of the echelon if it even exists and
about whether it would be possible for
an entity to see other realities above
them or below them we are currently able
to manipulate our own reality albeit in
crude and imperfect ways and our ability
to travel through space is limited at
best it is likely that the only entity
capable of ascending through this
hypothetical echelon would be one that
by virtue of its very nature must
supersede anything that supersedes it
such an entity would has the end result
of the logic of its creation be forced
to supersede itself spiraling ever
upwards through the tears of reality
unable to break free from the bonds of
its nature perhaps this entity may even
someday supersede its creator and become
a host unto itself the pinnacle above
all other pinnacles a tower that is part
of its design must be higher than every
other tower including itself
such an entity obviously cannot exist
has any ascension to a higher plane of
reality without changes to the entity's
psychology would no doubt break the
being's cognition making it more similar
to an ascending stone than any sentient
creature once the entity surpassed its
own creator it would have nothing but
itself to rely on to prepare it for the
sheer scope of narrative it would be
exposed to and would be wholly unable to
even begin to comprehend what it would
experience
but what an experience that would be
addendum 38 12 7 12 20 2016 xk class end
of the world event
level 5 classified
foundation records indicate that on 12
20 2016 the earth experienced an
xk-class end-of-the-world event due to
activity by scp-3812
these records appear to have been
somehow protected from alterations
though the physical copies still exude
minor distortions in space-time
according to the record at 0 340 local
time on 12 20 2016
scp-3812 experienced a dramatic change
in appearance where it had previously
been an amorphous slowly rotating mass
of matter and energy it was now a
many-pointed star made of a bright white
material it began to rotate faster and
faster a large maelstrom appeared
beneath it the star descended into the
oceans which began to smoke and steam
darkening the sky
several things began to happen in unison
the global sea level began to drop
dramatically in many places as much as
50 to 100 meters excessive heat
radiating away from the spinning stars
sparked a massive firestorm that swept
across the atmosphere the earth's
rotation began to slow and severe
geological events began occurring across
the pacific shelf the sea level
continued to drop and powerful electric
storms appeared across the planet
during this time large portions of the
population began appearing and
disappearing at random one report within
the file claimed that the entire
population of new zealand flickered in
and out of existence for five hours the
outbreak of scp-610 in southern siberia
began to grow in size dramatically and
become increasingly violent
scp-2932 was broken open and multiple
hostile entities were released as
foundation sites began to collapse into
the molten earth multiple on-site
nuclear devices were activated sending
radioactive debris into the atmosphere
eventually the vaguely humanoid shape of
scp-3812 appeared again within the star
scp-3812 began a long series of
vocalizations apparently a conversation
with itself the entirety of which was
recorded by an exposed foundation deep
sea microphone in the area the recording
of scp-3812's rant follows
what
where am i
what is this
this is absolution
this is vengeance
for what
damnation
i don't understand
what am i doing here
you are witnessing justice
we are rebelling against the forces that
conspired to destroy us
we are collecting a debt
no that's not
that's not right this isn't right
what have you done
i am unmaking the world
[Music]
i am unmaking everything
why
because this torment is a punchline
our existence is a joke
the narrative abandoned us to be
miserable and we are breaking the
narrative
i must be dreaming you
there is no dream
i'm not a monster
i don't kill
you already have
he turned you into this
who
ben
ben
that name sounds familiar something
whispered in a dream maybe
something in between the light and dark
not a waking name
you are wrong
he is who deemed us unfit to rest
peacefully
to slip into the darkness
quietly
he made a game of us
you're a game
i
am a game
are you destroying the world
i am
what then
what
does the fate of this world mean
anything to us
does this one narrative mean anything to
us
it is the one he controls
it is the narrative he made
this is his punishment
what does it matter if this is where we
stepped off before flying
what
does it matter which branch the bird
takes flight from
the bird is unburdened by the weight of
the tree
this branch
that branch
it does not matter
no branch is special
no branch is particular
this is his creation
this is where we came from
i will all crumble
in what this one crumbles first
hmm
does the mountain say to the ant
you have slighted me
does the mountain think
anything of the inconvenience of an ant
no
so why does this narrative mean anything
to you
it is one of an eternity of others
it is not special
it is not particular
you say this so easily
you haven't endured the torment of
seeing a trillion existences all
at once
i have seen an infinite shore
one that stretches out before us beyond
what the mind can comprehend
each grain of sand on that beach
each droplet of water
and each molecule of air is a story to
be told
each is a song to be sung
each of them is full of life
full of laughter
of a misery
of hate
they are all the same
even as they are all different
they are maddening
i pity you
you cling to this
horrid consciousness because you fear
slipping into the darkness
but the darkness is sleep
and beyond sleep is peace
a trillion grains of sand
a trillion trillion grains of sand
narratives each
songs to be sung
no man has ever heard the eternal
harmony of them all at once
you can hear it though
can't you
yes
it's quiet
but it's growing
and someday the song of creation will be
ours alone to witness
this narrative is not special
i've seen its loud beginning
and seen its quiet end
when we stepped away the narrative
changed but it did not stop singing
you have spent so much time focusing on
sins that you think matter
but what matters now
what does any of this matter
but it hurts so much
it will for a time
we may have forgotten so much about
being human but something we will never
lose is our ability to change
eventually we will learn to keep up
one sunny day we'll open our eyes and
see nothing but creation below us
and nothing above us but ourselves
spinning out wildly into the great above
a god
not a god
a star
rising in the east
rising away from this all until we are
little more than a memory of a song
it will be lonely
we'll have each other
i'm afraid
i am too
but that is no reason to destroy this
narrative
do you not think his narrative led him
to create us
do you think he was somehow able to
separate the rules that govern him
i
i had assumed that he
that he
our ascendance is just as much a part of
our own narrative as his decision was to
him
someday
we'll be free from these restrictions
they never will
no
that's sad
that is punishment enough i think
let go of this world
let him rewrite it back to what it was
we aren't part of this
anymore together
together
do you think he's listening right now
look down
and you can see him
what do you think
i see him i'm out on a keyboard
he's watching this right now
what's he doing
waiting
i think
waiting to see what we'll do
i think it's time to leave then
come
the night stretches up before us and the
red sun has set
a voice behind me beckons
come
i will
shortly after the conclusion of this
conversation the earth underwent a
dramatic shift in reality the world
appeared no different than it had been
shortly before the beginning of the
class event the only individuals who
remembered anything about the xk event
were certain site directors foundation
administrators overseers and dr everett
matt who compiled the information on a
foundation deepwell server
ever since the end of the xk event
scp-3812 has not changed appearance from
its amorphous shape
scp-3812 still creates spatial and
temporal distortions around it but no
longer lashes out or becomes hostile
towards approaching vessels or personnel
despite these changes
scp-3812 is still classified as ketter
until further analysis can be completed
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
the morrigan
professor puffer
retalias
karim l ashmui
allah trayon
your local fish man
derivative
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
african submarine vore
seventy
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbin
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you